so i'm gonna give you a little
background thomas soul is an economist
okay so that's that's his background and
he he writes books okay i it's thomas
sowell if you see this i would love to
interview you please come on thomas but
he doesn't do interviews often so this
interview has five million views
okay okay let's here we go
it happens to me all the time and it
happened just this week
a young person i'd never met introduced
himself to me and said that when he saw
our guest today
on an earlier episode of this program he
felt he was seeing a man who knew how to
think
dr thomas sowell on uncommon knowledge
now
[Music]
welcome to uncommon knowledge i'm peter
robinson
thomas sol has studied and taught
economics intellectual history and
social policy at institutions that
include cornell brandeis ucla and
amherst now a senior fellow at the
hoover institution dr soule has
published more than a dozen books
including the classic a conflict of
visions
coming soon a revised edition of his
most recent volume discrimination and
disparities
tom soul welcome thank you
you
so before
he gets into it um it's like for me it's
cool to see
like just black people in like spaces
like that and just to hear like the
accolades i feel like they're they're
out there but
we just don't hear about them and i was
like wondering like i wonder why we
don't but that's what i wanted to say
yeah i think part of his problem is he
hates the media so he really he really
doesn't do interviews often hey guys and
he's still so well known in in the space
of youtube yeah if you know you know
grew up in harlem dropped out of high
school to join the marine corps during
the korean war
received an undergraduate degree from
harvard
a masters from columbia
and your doctorate from the university
of chicago
all of which pales by comparison with
the fact that you once tried out for the
brooklyn dodgers
but
during this period from harlem
to the university of chicago
throughout your 20s you've said you
spent most of the decade of your 20s as
a marxist yes
oh wait do you know what a marxist is no
i was like uh who wait i
to
wanna
google
i get the definition right but i think
that just means more left guys this is
my new merch on the screen if you want
to buy the merch
marks
okay marxism is a method of
socioeconomic analysis that uses
materialistic interpretation of
historical
oh god
i want to say just more liberal we'll
just go with that yeah because i still
was like
sorry let us know in the comments
and then i have to google the big words
that they use in definition i'm just
like
huh i i think it's just more left like
leaning more liberal
why what was it what
what was the attraction
well i guess i first
was uh
very puzzled see you there there's one
little question i would make
at age 16 i was a dropout high school
dropout
and i went to work full time
as a western union messenger
and delivering telegrams did lorraine
tell her we better say that because
there will be a generation that won't
know what western union was because yeah
that's true too right uh
and so i i work i worked in the
area of manhattan called the chelsea
district which is around 23rd street
ninth avenue
and at the end of the day i had several
ways of getting back home like the
easiest
fastest way was with a subway which was
a nickel in those days
when i was feeling flush i might go for
a bus
for a dime and then when i was really
getting reckless i would take the fifth
avenue bus which was the elite of the
buses
uh
was 15 cents and so i would walk over to
fifth avenue take that bus
and it would take me up uh through all
the
glamorous parts of fifth avenue past the
empire state building
uh past the great
stores and things of that sort
uh and then on 57th street it would turn
and
this is just
the elite part of town sure right right
there the park starts yes and then and
you
know this park starts at 59th oh sorry
50s 57th i would turn over again the
same kind of scene past carnegie hall
right a columbus circle there was no
trump tower at that time and uh on up to
about 72nd street and go out to fifth
ave out to the riverside drive which is
another elite area so for miles after
that you have all these wonderful luxury
apartment buildings and so on
and finally around
129th 30th street
uh it would go on a long viaduct
and then he would do a right turn back
into the occupied area and there you'd
see the tenements
and i would wonder why is this
i mean why why this huge disparity
and there was nobody else there was no
other other explanation around
there there was nothing there was
nothing there other than marxism
uh i know i stumbled across i had not
read marks
but i i i bought a second hand pair a
set of encyclopedias small set
for some ridiculously low price
and there
where you grew up did you ever
see that whereas like one
one road can have all these nice big
houses but then on the next block it's
just like completely different
i grew up on 40 acres
okay we didn't really have like
neighborhoods
that i grew up on a bunch of land was
that how it was where you grew up kind
of i grew up i grew up in like a
a township so it was a small town and it
had like farms on the outskirts but as
soon as you got out of
the town and into the next city so the
next city for me
um it was holly and then fenton was the
next city it was nice and then it was
like davisburg and waterford
where the next city's over and those
were like nice areas they always called
holly like the rednecks a podunk town
because we had a lot of farms and stuff
in it and so i i saw that a little bit
growing up i didn't see it a lot more
until i got to
california where i'm at in california
it's
like low income area but literally if
you drive up the street it's
nice houses nice area and it's such a
a big difference but like within
seconds or minutes between each other
and
i've always wondered like why
is that and i just was wondering if you
had experienced that um actually when
you were talking i remembered it was
like that in milwaukee how i think about
it like milwaukee
um they had a town called shore shortage
i think it was or shore
shorewood shorewood that's it
yeah no no sure
and i was in downtown milwaukee and like
where i lived it was like
not a safe area like my car got broken
into a couple times yeah yeah
partially because i forgot to lock it
so it didn't really get broken into it
i don't really have anything in it but
they took my charger i was salty okay
i could not charge my car
the next
and like a couple coins but i was like
whatever but uh at least i didn't take
the whole car exactly how hard it was
i'm not
no no so um then
but like i moved that summer into uh
like with my church oh okay and that the
people i lived with it was like the
nicest area
so so it's interesting but that was
within a couple miles honestly like
complete opposite ends it's it's crazy
and if you get deeper into like la it's
even
broader and it's
it's just interesting yeah
i looked up karl marx i'd heard the name
and the stuff that he said
seemed to make sense
and then later on i would get more and
more into it
uh and uh uh the
argument was that the the rich had
gotten rich by taking from the poor
right
and well that that was that was one
explanation but it was interesting there
was no other explanation out there
really and that's true largely in our
colleges universities today but so so by
the time you went to harvard undergrad
well so
you drop out at the age of 16
and you start reading marks in your late
teens i know i start reading walks
yes 1949
at age 19. age 19. and then you're in
the marine corps for
a couple years what what was it two
three years oh two years it was actually
one
one year 11 months and five days but
who's counting
all right so by the time you went to
harvard
you had already become intellectually
engaged with marxism yes and remained
and harvard didn't talk you out of it
and
the study of economics at harvard didn't
talk you out of it nor did getting a
masters at columbia nor did getting a
doctorate
at chicago
dissuade you from marxism is that and
you studied with milton friedman of all
people how could you have sat in milton
friedman's classroom and remained a
marxist something i'm going to give you
a little bit of a background so um when
he's saying like how could you be a marx
is he saying like more liberal economic
policies i think guys i could be wrong
so like basically more like like free
stuff from the government where
conservatives are more like
individualistic policies okay which
they're gonna get more into so um the
economist they're talking about is a
very conservative economist so he's
saying how could you have like studied
with him and still come out left okay
and the
the guy that he was studying with is
more individual
yeah individualistic policies so less
like government handouts does that make
sense yes yes yes it is it was just
stubborn
but
what really changed me uh
was not the university of chicago
it was
my first job working in a professional
capacity for the government i was a
summer intern this is after chicago or
no no while i was still a graduate
student got it uh and so during the
summer vacation i worked in the u.s
department of labor and i
began to realize from a number of things
that
the government is not simply the
personification of the general will like
rousseau or others
the government is an institute
government institutions have their own
institutional
uh
uh one involved in minimum wage law i
was a big supporter of that
but i also knew that there was an
argument that minimum wage law is simply
price low wage workers out of a job
and uh my my first assignment was dealt
with minimum wages in puerto rico and as
i looked at the numbers i would see as
they would jack up the minimum wage this
is a number number of jobs would go down
and so forth but there were two
explanations one was that of the
economist that you priced the people out
of out of a job and the other was that
there are there were
hurricanes in the country puerto rico
you see
during the
sugar harvesting and therefore i was
studying the sugar industry and
therefore it destroyed a lot of the crop
therefore you wouldn't hire as many
workers now in chicago had been taught
that if there are two different theories
there should be somewhat some empirical
evidence in principle that could
distinguish what would happen under one
theory from what would happen under the
other right and so i wrestled with that
for the most of the summer and one
morning i came in and i said i got it
what we need are data on the amount of
sugar clean standing in the fields
before the hurricane struck
and as i waited for the congratulations
i could see stricken looks around me in
the room like this guy has stumbled on
something they will ruin us all
you know
and they said well we don't have those
data oh i'll bet the department of
agriculture has he said well well but
that doesn't mean we haven't
do you think that people like he was
saying have
certain data
to essentially make things better but
it wouldn't benefit them so they don't
bring it out
do you see it you can't unsee it
once you see it you can't i always
thought that but i didn't want it to be
true
well it's because like
like the minimum wage law it's so it's
so easy
like that you can be
i think you don't even need to be an
economist to understand that if you jack
the price up of something peop less
people are gonna do it yeah so a lot you
know who hurts a lot from minimum wage
laws teenagers
really yeah because if you say um
we're only hiring people like let's say
they jacked it up to 30 an hour
who are the first people that are gonna
go
at least skills yeah teenagers
okay and low-skilled people that are
trying to move up they can't get those
jobs
no okay that does make sense yeah i'd
like that's like to me that's so why why
did when they march the streets and they
act like they're
they're
fighting for the little guy they're
saying oh we're doing this for poor
people but that's not what happens my
parents run a business yeah if you jack
up the prices they either go to other
countries and hire people
or
or they just don't they figure out how
to hire less people or get it you see
the mcdonald's here the kiosks
that too just get robots to do because
you don't have to pay robots and it's
the same people that say oh i'm doing
such a good job i'm helping out poor
people but they're not doing [ __ ]
they're just making it better for
themselves essentially
man
that's that's interesting one funny
thing that i wanted to say that i
noticed about him because he was like
because the um the interviewer had given
his accolades and his backgrounds and
then he was like i'll make one
correction and he went through it his
like whole life story and i'm like
that's one thing that's one thing about
old black people they're gonna give you
every single detail about their life
it's like you could give like the big
points but they're gonna say i walked
here five minutes and i turned left went
right then i walked five minutes that
way i'd spun around i'm gonna give you
every single little detail i love it i
love
it you'd have to have a a request go up
the chain of command to the secretary of
labor he would then confer with the
secretary of agriculture it would come
down the chain of command and
the department of agriculture to whoever
has those numbers and so on i said good
well they say a journey of a thousand
miles begins with a single step so i
will now submit my request to the
secretary of labor which i did and i am
still patiently awaiting this reply
and the institutional fear of the number
was what that
oh the u.s department of labor
administers the minimum wage law
and i and the uh money and the careers
of perhaps a third or some other
significant percentage of the member of
the labor department sell resources come
from administering the minimum wage law
one of the real forces of all this is
that the law itself section 4-d i still
remember requires the labor department
to study the employment effects of
minimum wages and those studies are
absolutely a farce
in fact some years after i left i did an
article saying why those let those
studies were a farce and when i came
back later on to the labor department to
do some research one of the older
librarians who remembered me turned to
the younger librarian and she said this
is the man who wrote that article that
has everybody up in arms